>> Gutfeld: HAPPY FRIDAY,
EVERYONE.
IT WILL BE A GREAT SHOW TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, A DISCLAIMER.
>> WARNING, GREG IS STILL COMING
DOWN FROM A STRONG ANESTHETIC.
WE'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYTHING THAT HE SAYS IN THE
FOLLOWING SHOW.
>> Gutfeld: TRUE, NOT LYING.
A HAPPY FRIDAY FOR ME.
YES, I JUST HAD AN ENDOSCOPY.
THEY SHOVE A CAMERA DOWN YOUR
THROAT TO SEE HOW STUFF IS
WORKING.
THAT VIDEO'S RATINGS ARE STILL
HIGHER THAN CN NSHGs.
BUT THANKFULLY, THEY DIDN'T FIND
ANYTHING SCARY, EXCEPT FOR DANA
PERINO'S CLASS RING.
THERE'S A FEW DIAMONDS MISSING
FROM IT, BUT I'M HOPING MY
PROCTOLOGIST WILL FIND THOSE
NEXT WEEK.
BUT IN ORDER TO DO THAT
PROCEDURE, THEY PUT ME ON A DRUG
THAT KNOCKED ME OUT.
SO, FORGIVE ME IF I MAKE LESS
SENSE THAN JOE BIDEN SPEAKING
WITHOUT A TELEPROMPTER.
BUT AT LEAST I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE CAT.
ANYWAY -- LAST NIGHT, A DEBATE
ERUPTED OVER THE BROOKLYN NETS'
GUARD KYRIE IRVING WHO REFUSED
THE COVID VACCINE.
I DON'T FOLLOW PROFESSIONAL
BADMINTON, BUT THIS IS A BIG
DEAL, NEW YORK CITY REQUIRES A
PROOF OF THE VAX FOR ENTRY INTO
THE ARENA WHERE THE NETS PLAY.
SO ON TUESDAY, THE NETS SAID
IRVING WON'T PLAY UNTIL HE'S
VAXXED.
HE AIN'T DOING IT.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
>> WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
IF YOU FELT UNCOMFORTABLE GOING
INTO THE SEASON WHEN YOU WERE
PROMISED THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
EXEMPTIONS OR THAT YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TO BE FORCED TO GET THE
VACCINE?
I'M STAYING GROUNDED IN WHAT I
BELIEVE IN.
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BEING
ANTI-VAXXED.
IT'S NOT BEING ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER.
IT'S WHAT FEELS GUOED TO ME.
I CHOSE TO BE UNVACCINATED.
IT'S MY CHOICE.
I WOULD ASK YOU TO RESPECT THAT
CHOICE.
>> Gutfeld: WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS NOT HIS REASONED OPINION BUT
HOW IT AFFECTS PEOPLE WHO HEAR
IT.
IT'S NOW A PICKUP GAME OF THE
SHIRTS VERSUS THE SKINS.
SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
CHECK OUT THE DEBATE ON THIS
INTRIGUING PROGRAM THAT FEATURES
FIVE PANELISTS, ONE REALLY,
REALLY HOT GUY, AND IT'S ON AT
5:00 P.M., BUT I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE NAME.
RULES ARE RULES.
THIS GUY IS WRECKING HIS LIFE
RIGHT NOW FOR NO REAL REASON AND
IT'S ABSOLUTE STUBBORNNESS BASED
ON NOTHING.
>> JESSE?
>> GERALDO, YOU'RE MAD AT THIS
GUY.
>> HE'S NOT JUST HURTING
HIMSELF.
>> HE'S --
>> YOU'RE BEING PLAYED.
YOU'RE BEING PLAYED.
>> YOU'RE BEING STUBBORN.
>> LET ME EXPLAIN.
>> YOU'RE BEING BLOCK HEADED.
>> YOU'RE BEING MANIPULATED TO
DISAGREE WITH SOMEBODY.
THIS IS AN ARTIFICIAL DIVISION
AND WE SHOULDN'T PLAY INTO THIS.
THIS IS WHAT THE MANDATE DID.
>> IT'S WEIRD WATCHING YOURSELF
ON TV WHILE YOU'RE ON TV.
DON LEMON DOES THAT TO DOUBLE
HIS VIEWERSHIP.
ANYWAY, I FEAR THAT GERALDO
MISSED MY POINT.
THAT THE ANGER HE FELT TOWARD
IRVING IS NOT CAUSED BY IRVING
AT ALL.
IT'S CAUSED BY THE SITUATION
CREATED BY PEOPLE IN POWER IN
ORDER TO CREATE CONFLICT TO KEEP
US AT EACH OTHER'S THROATS LIKE
JOY AND WHOOPI FIGHTING OVER THE
LAST ECLAIR IN THE GREEN ROOM --
THEY LIKE SWEETS.
THE ELITES ARE TRYING TO FIGHT A
PROXY WAR WITH EACH OTHER
THROUGH THE CITIZENS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IT SEEMS TO
BE WORKING.
IRVING WAS TRYING TO FOCUS ON
GETTING A SHOT IN THE NECK, NOT
GETTING A SHOT IN THE ARM, BUT
GERALDO FELT GENUINE ANGER
TOWARD HIM, THE SAME KIND I FEEL
TOWARDS KILMEADE WHEN HE WON'T
RETURN MY SWIM TRUNKS.
DOESN'T EVEN OWN A POOL.
BUT THE ANGER IS MISPLACED.
IT'S FURY MANUFACTURED BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT WHO ARE SCARED TO
DEATH OF LIABILITY AND THEREFORE
RISK.
BUT THEY'RE ALLISTERIFIED OF YOU
AND ME OR ME AND GERALDO IF WE
HAPPEN TO EVER AGREE WHICH IS
HARD TO DO IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THAT MUSTACHE.
THAT IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT KIND
OF TWO POINTER.
LITTLE SPORTS JOKE.
BUT IF WE ALL GOT ALONG DESPITE
OUR POLITICAL HEALTH OR HEIGHT
DIFFERENCES THAT MAKES IT HARDER
FOR THE ARISTOCRACY TO CONTROL
YOU AND FOR THE VIDEO MAKE A
BUCK.
THE MEDIA LOSES POWER WHEN WE
REFUSE THE TRAPS THEY SET FOR
US.
WE SEE IT'S EGGED ON, THAT
AREN'T TRUE.
CNN FOSTERED THE NARRATIVE AND
WOVE IT TO A RACIAL CONFLICT
THAT MUSHROOMED INTO A
MONSTROSITY OF LIES AND
POLITICS.
OTHERS WHO WISH TO PIT THE SEXES
AGAINST EACH OTHER DO SO BECAUSE
IT MAKES CAREERS AND ACADEMIA
AND JOBS FOR PEOPLE IN HUMAN
RESOURCES.
THEY DO IT WITH GUYS AND
STRAIGHTS, TRANS AND GUYS, DOGS
AND CATS, FOX AND FRIENDS.
CONFLICT SELLS.
THAT'S WHY EVERY GOOD BOND FILM
HAS THE VILLAIN.
THAT'S WHY THE VIEW AND CNN
SUCKS.
WE PUSH IT AROUND ON THE STREET,
THEY'RE RAKING IT IN WITH THE
CLICK BAIT.
IF ONLY WE GOT ALONG, THEIR JOBS
WOULD SPIN FASTER THAN A STORY
ON HUNTER'S LAP TOP AND PEOPLE'S
POWER WOULD GROW.
NOW WE'RE IN NEW CONFLICTS,
VAXED VERSUS UNVAXED.
MASKS VERSUS NO MASKS.
YOU SEE IT GINNED UP EVERYWHERE.
THE NBA PLAYER, WHY GET MAD OVER
SOMEONE YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW IS
MAKING A DECISION FOR HIMSELF,
UNLESS IT'S SOMETHING LIKE
TALKING LOUDLY ON A CELL PHONE
IN A MOVIE THEATER, IN THAT
CASE, STAB THE JERK.
DON'T STAB THE JERK.
THAT'S A JOKE.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT, JUST
REALIZE IT'S CNN AND BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TROLLING YOU AND
US.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S KIND OF CLEAR
THAT SOMEONE WHO IS YOUNG, LEAN,
AND INCREDIBLY FIT SUCH AS KYRIE
AND MYSELF DOES NOT HAVE THE
SAME RISK PROFILE AS SOMEONE
WITH A PRE-EXISTING CONDITION.
UNLESS UNBEKNOWNST TO MEKHI ROOE
WAS DATED CAT.
HE POSES NO THREAT TO GERALDO OR
ME OR OUR FAMILIES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
BUT WE'RE LIVING IN A TIME OF
CONFORMITY.
IF YOU DON'T CONFORM, YOU'RE
STUNNED LIKE GERALD NADLER
SKINNY-DIPPING AT A PUBLIC POOL.
IF YOU FEEL YOURSELF GETTING
ANGRY AND YOU'RE GIVEN TWO
CHOICES, IT'S A BINARY PRISON OF
IDEAS.
IT'S A DESIRED PHENOMENON
CREATED BY A THIRD PARTY.
IT CREATES CONTENT FOR TV
PRODUCERS AND DISTRACTS THE
POPULACE FROM THE REAL BAD
THINGS GOING ON LIKE CRIME,
MENTAL ILLNESS AND RELENTLESS
IBS CAUSED BY SWALLOWING CLASS
RINGS.
IF WE FIGHT MOST OURSELF,
WE CAN'T FIGHT THEM AND WE CAN
CONTINUE IGNORING REAL INJUSTICE
AND GET RICH OFF OF YOU ALONG
THE WAY.
SO MANDATES BECAME ANOTHER TOOL
TO SPLIT US APART.
BUT THE MEDIA'S ARGUMENT THERE
HAS TO BE A DEEP-SEEDED HATRED
AMONGST AMERICANS IS MUCH LIKE
AL CAPONE'S VAULT.
ONCE YOU CRACK IT OPEN, THERE'S
NOTHING REALLY THERE.
ONCE YOU SEE IT, YOU CAN'T UNSEE
IT.
LIKE WHEN YOU SEE GERALDO
SHIRTLESS.
SADLY, THERE'S NO VACCINE FOR
THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Gutfeld: WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
HE'S A SUCCESSFUL COMEDIAN, AND
ACTOR.
WHICH MEANS AT ONE POINT IN HIS
CAREER, HE WAS ALSO A SUCCESSFUL
WAITER.
HER LAST NAME IS ITALIAN FOR
"TALKS TOO FAST," OUTNUMBERED
CO-HOSTS, EMILY CAMPANIO.
HIS NOVELS ARE SO DELICIOUS THEY
SHOULD BE IN THE COOKBOOK
SECTION.
"UP IN THE AIR" AUTHOR WALTER
KEARNS.
SHE'S GOT BRAINS, SHE'S GOT
BEAUTY.
AND IF YOU FEED HER BEANS, SHE'S
JUST A LITTLE TOOTY, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
WALTER?
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS -- WITH
THIS COVID STUFF IS WE CANNOT
DISCOUNT THE -- BY THE WAY, NICE
TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, I MISSED YOU.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
ISN'T THAT CUTE?
WE CAN'T DISCOUNT THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE WHEN GIVEN THE CHANCE TO
FEEL RIGHTEOUS, YOU KNOW, FROM
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS TO TV ANCHORS
WILL TAKE THAT SHOT, RIGHT?
THAT'S WHY I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
SEEING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WHEN I WAS A KID, WE USED TO
READ A SHORT STORY CALLED "THE
LOTTERY" ABOUT A SMALL
PROTESTANT HOMETOWN I THINK IN
VERMONT.
EVERY YEAR TO MAKE THE CROPS
GROW, THE FARMERS FORMED A
CIRCLE, PICKED ONE AND STONED
THEM TO DEATH.
SO THERE'S AN ANCIENT INSTINCT
FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE A SCAPEGOAT
PAY FOR ALL OF THE DIFFICULTIES
IN LIFE IN THE THOUGHT THAT IT
WILL BRING BACK NORMALCY IF WE
SACRIFICE THEM.
AND TODAY IT'S HIM.
BUT YOU KNOW I REMEMBER WHEN
MOHAMMED ALI WOULDN'T GO TO THE
VIETNAM WAR.
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES ARE PEOPLE
TOO.
WE TREAT THEM LIKE PAID CIRCUS
PERFORMERS. THEY COME OUT, SHOW
THEY HAVE A CONSCIENCE, AND THEY
DON'T NEED THE APPLAUSE AND
ACCLAIM WE GIVE THEM.
BUT PERSONALLY, HE'S MADE ALL OF
THE RIGHT DECISIONS ABOUT HIS
BODY HIS WHOLE LIFE.
HE MADE IT TO THE NBA.
I THINK HE'S PROBABLY STILL
MAKING THEM.
BUT HE'S SUDDENLY A MORON IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
NOW THE LOTTERY, NOW YOU SAY IS
A BAD IDEA.
>> NOT IF YOU WANT THE CROPS TO
GROW.
>> Gutfeld: EXACTLY, SOME THINGS
TAKE PRIORITY, JAMIE.
LONG TIME SINCE I'VE SEEN YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN LIVING IN -- STILL
IN FAIR BANK, ALASKA.
>> FAIR BANKS, ALASKA.
THAT'S RIGHT.
I TRY TO GET GEOGRAPHICALLY AS
FAR AWAY FROM WHERE I WOULD BE
SUCCESSFUL.
>> Gutfeld: WELL, YOU'VE DONE
QUITE WELL.
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL IN YOUR
FAILURE.
>> UH-HUH.
>> Gutfeld: WHAT DO YOU MAKE ON
THIS STORY.
WHERE DO YOU STAND OR SIT?
>> CAN I SAY FIRST OF ALL, I
KNOW YOU HAD THE ENDOSCOPY AND
YOU'RE ON SOME DRUGS.
I'M ON PAINKILLERS, THIS
MORNING, I HAD ACCESS TO SOME.
SO --
>> Gutfeld: THAT MIGHT BE THE
BEST JOKE I EVER HEARD.
BUT AGAIN, I'M REALLY HIGH.
>> I TOLD THAT JOKE BEFORE BUT
NO ONE COULD HEAR IT BECAUSE I
WAS IN ALASKA. I FEEL LIKE KYRIE
IS BRAVE.
I THINK HE'S A BRAVE GUY.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPRESSIVE
BECAUSE HE'S A RICH GUY.
I THINK WE CAN SAY, HE MAKES
$400,000 A GAME, I THINK I SAW,
THAT'S TRUE?
FOR $400,000, I WOULD TAKE THE
ANTHRAX VACCINE.
I REALLY WOULD.
I KNOW LeBRON -- STEFAN CURRY
GOT THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON?
THEY'RE SAYING IT'S JUST AS
EFFECTIVE AS HAVING ONE OF THOSE
CIRCULAR BAND AIDS.
SO --
>> Gutfeld: GOOD TO SEE YOU,
JAMIE?
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Gutfeld: SO MUCH TALENT.
SUCH AN EMPTY SPACE.
EMILY, DON'T YOU FEEL THIS
DEBATE COULD BE SETTLED IF WE
GOT RID OF LAWYERS IN THE MEDIA?
FROM THE ROOM?
>> HEY.
I WAS JUST GOING TO -- THE MEDIA
AND A LAWYER.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY I
SHOULDN'T NOW, YOU DON'T DESERVE
IT.
I THINK A DISCLAIMER IN THE
BEGINNING PASSES LEGAL MUSTER,
JUST SAYING.
KYRIE SAID IT BEST, WHAT
WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WERE TOLD
THERE WOULD BE EXEMPTIONS,
EXCEPTIONS, ALTERNATIVES.
LOOK AT ANDREW WIGGINS FROM THE
WARRIORS WHO APPLIED FOR A
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION AND WAS
DENIED.
WE WERE TOLD THAT COVID NEGATIVE
TESTS WOULD SUFFICE FOR THE
ATHLETES WHO CHOSE NOT TO GET
THE VACCINE.
WE WERE TOLD THAT WITHIN NEW
YORK CITY AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT ENCROACHMENT KEEPS
CREEPING.
SO KYRIE COULD STAND TO USE
$15.5 MILLION HE WILL THIS
SEASON.
THAT MEANS HE STAND TO LOSE IT.
WHAT ABOUT THE NAVY SAILORS WHO
ARE BEING DISCHARGED LESS THAN
HONORABLY AND LOSING BENEFITS,
LOSING THEIR PENSION.
THESE ARE HARDWORKING AMERICANS
WHO HAVE SERVED OUR COUNTRIES
THAT ARE LOSING EVERYTHING THAT
HAVE MOUTHS TO FEED BECAUSE THEY
CHOSE TO HAVE AUTONOMY OVER
THEIR BODY AND MADE THEIR OWN
DECISION, RELIGIOUS OR
OTHERWISE.
IF IT DOESN'T PASS AN ARBITRARY
TEST ACCORDING TO COACH OR
MEDICAL EXAMINER AT THE MOMENT
IT'S NOT APPROVED.
THE MANDATE -- HE'S RIGHT.
THE MANDATE IS WHAT'S DIFFICULT
TO STOMACH.
EVERYONE IS STEPPING UP AGAINST
HIM WITH WHATEVER PLATFORM WE
HAVE, WE SHOULD APPLAUD RATHER
THAN CONDEMN.
>> Gutfeld: YEAH, I DON'T -- I
THINK IT'S THE -- IT'S THE EDICT
FROM THE GOVERNMENT IN NEW YORK
FORCING THE TEAM'S HAND.
WE SEE THE GOVERNMENT FREELANCE
THE AUTHORITARIANISM.
THE COMPANY'S CHOICE TO DO THAT,
AND YOU WORK AT THE COMPANY.
NO, IT'S THE GOVERNMENT TELLING
THE COMPANY TO DO IT SAYING YOU
CAN'T WORK HERE.
>> WE WATCH THAT VIDEO.
HE SAYS, IT'S MY CHOICE, I'M
ASKING YOU TO RESPECT MY CHOICE.
HE DOESN'T SAY BOYCOTT THE NBA.
HE DOESN'T EVEN SAY AGREE WITH
ME.
YOU TURN ON THE TV AND PEOPLE
ARE LIKE, NO, WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT A HORRIBLE
PERSON YOU ARE ALL NIGHT LONG,
ACTUALLY.
IT'S A CERTAIN POINT THAT IT'S A
PSYCHOTIC REACTION.
SOMEONE SAY IT'S MY CHOICE,
RESPECT MY CHOICE.
>> Gutfeld: WE'RE FORCING PEOPLE
IN THE PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
THERE'S A MILLION IDEAS, A
MILLION STANCES BETWEEN AAHH AND
HEY.
THERE IS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY MY HANDS ARE
STILL UP HERE.
>> I LIKE YOU HIGH.
>> Gutfeld: I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON ANYMORE.
>> I TOOK PAINKILLERS TOO.
>> Gutfeld: WHY DIDN'T YOU
SHARE.
>> I THREW MY BACK OUT.
I TRY TO BE STEALTH WHEN I'M
STONED.
>> AM I THE ONLY SOBER ONE HERE?
THAT'S INSULTING TO ME.
>> Gutfeld: IT'S LIKE, IF YOU
GOT THEM, YOU GOT TO SHARE THEM.
>> I AGREE.
>> Gutfeld: UNLESS THERE'S A
FRIENDS --
>> PAINKILLERS ON THE BACK OF
THE BOTTLE SAID DO NOT MIX WITH
ALCOHOL.
BUT I READ THAT AS THIS WOULD
PROBABLY BE PRETTY GOOD IF YOU
MIX IT WITH ALCOHO